he's the Pulitzer Prize winning
columnist for the new york times who
with his wife Sheryl WuDunn co-authored
the book tightrope Americans reaching
for hope Nicholas Kristof is on ok so
listen let's first we'll get back to
this subject but I want to talk about
your book first cuz it's a fantastic
book and can you ever get past this
crisis and we will we will have to
contend with the fact that the same old
things that have been making people die
will still be making people to I nu 0 in
on what you call
I think deaths of despair in this
country what what are we talking about
when you say deaths of despair so we're
talking about deaths from drugs alcohol
and suicide which every two weeks kill
more Americans than died in the entire
Afghan and Iraq Wars and it's the story
of my hometown a quarter of the kids on
my old school bus where is it it's in
Yamhill Oregon right where the
Willamette Valley goes into the coastal
range of course I know it well okay so
and that's and this is a saying typical
of rural America this is a very rural
area it's it's it's kind of a Great
Depression that has struck parts of
America but not geographically but
demographically it is a crisis that has
hit working-class America so these
people would seem to be the ideal Bernie
Sanders voters they would seem to be
more ripe for a political revolution
than anybody but when you look at the
political map those areas were always
red what why do you think so the white
working-class is socially very
conservative economically though they
tend to be actually much more liberal
and so look if they go in the voting
booth and they were thinking about
abortion guns then they were vote for a
Republican but Democrats have to fight
for those votes and if they were
thinking about raising the minimum wage
if they were thinking about parental
leave increasingly if they were thinking
about health
here about expanding Medicaid then there
is a fighting chance to have them vote
Democratic so what our drug war was has
been a massive failure first it's one of
the worst policy failures in America and
bipartisan absolutely uh known for
Bloomberg hate spot yeah I mean it goes
way back earlier than that yeah yeah but
really I mean a guy who's supposed to be
so smart about so many things you know
okay so what does a good drug policy
look like so a good drug policy I mean
we actually have a good comparison in
the 1990s the US and Portugal we were
both wrestling with the heroin problem
right they both look at what you do the
u.s. double down on a law enforcement
toolbox and Portugal meanwhile convened
a panel and decriminalized
drug possession even heroin cocaine but
above all what they used was the public
health toolbox encouraging people to
providing treatment and the upshot is
that the number of heroin users in
Portugal has dropped by two-thirds
portugal now has the lowest drug
overdose rate in western europe and
meanwhile we lost 68 thousand americans
last year I know I'm always the bad guy
when I bring this up but I saw it in the
paper yesterday obesity the school of
when is it the Harvard Chan School of
Public Health at Harvard says in twenty
ten years not that it's not bad now half
the country in 2030 will be obese a
quarter will be severely obese forty
thousand deaths a month a month from
obesity and that is a big problem
absolutely about in the areas you're
talking about absolutely its enormous
but it's you can't just look at at the
moment that somebody is reaching for
some potato chips it's very much a
reflection of this miasma of depression
that has struck much of the country and
when people lose jobs lose good
well-paying jobs then they self-medicate
with methamphetamine they self-medicate
with alcohol
they also self-medicate with with soda
and and potato chips and so you know
there is no there's no silver bullet but
there are silver buckshot
and you can address that in part by
providing better paying jobs and
supporting education in these areas and
you know they that helps to address so
many of these problems together
you